how's it going everybody it's Warren and
welcome to part one of a two-part scoop
by Mikey Sutton with me and lords of the
long box and today we have a very
awesome scoop one that I've personally
been waiting to hear for a very long
time we have a character coming to the
MCU who is one of the strongest
characters ever written for Marvel
Comics and could quite possibly be the
strongest character if you exclude all
the godlike characters you've most
likely heard of Mikey by now he's leaked
a lot of stuff in our community in fact
yesterday he leaked the fact that
x-men's rogue could be coming in Captain
Marvel 2 and today he has a new scoop
for us so be sure to subscribe when
notifications turned on so you don't
miss any of my ki Sutton's exclusive
scoops today we are talking about
century he has the power of 1 million
exploding Suns his name is Robert
Reynolds and he will punch his way
through the MCU with a world shattering
impact according to Mikey Sutton and his
sources he has heard that Marvel Studios
has thought about the century for the
past few years but it's just now that
the talks took a serious turn
- Marvel Studios they view the century
as their possible Superman while Zack
Snyder's dark version of the Man of
Steel seemed ill suited for the basic
essence of the character Kevin Feige
will be freed from such conditions with
the century
Mikey states that currently Marvel
Studios does not know where he will be
introduced
however a Disney Plus series with a
budget even higher than the initial MCU
stream in entries which are already
equal to their cinematic counterparts is
being discussed the MCU is brimming with
characters from the gold and silver and
bronze ages but as for something more
modern the century will fill that void
pun intended if you know about the
century there is somebody else coming to
the MCU and you can jump over to Lords
of the long boxes YouTube channel to
check out part 2 of the scoop but let's
break down the century for those of you
who may not know who he is the century
is a relatively new character he hasn't
been around that long he's only been
here since 2000 but he's one of the most
powerful heroes that Marvel has ever
seen he has quite a complicated
backstory
he gets his powers from a super serum
and the Sun when we first meet Robert
Reynolds he doesn't realize that he is
the century but he drinks a serum and he
gets his powers back and starts to
remember who he was before he remembers
that he was once a superhero called the
century who fought alongside mr.
fantastics
spider-man and the Hulk he then sets out
to discover why nobody remembers him and
why he forgot about his past while
talking with mr. fantastic they realized
what had happened an evil being called
the void threatened earth but they went
on to discover that the century and the
void were two halves of the same person
so in order to save the world Robert
Reynolds erased his memory from the mind
of nearly every person on earth even his
own once he regained his powers and
everybody remembered him they realized
that the void was once again threatening
earth and Reynolds realized that he
would have to make the same sacrifice
again so with the help of mr. fantastic
and Doctor Strange the memory of the
century and Robert Reynolds was once
again erased from the world now we would
eventually see Robert Reynolds again he
would appear inside the supervillain
prison the raft as it turns out he
voluntary put himself in the raft
because he believed that he murdered his
wife
however the Avengers come and break him
out and they learned that the villain
mastermind put a virus inside of his
head that creates delusions and the
existence of the void which is actually
Reynolds's repressed persona so Robert
Reynolds the century and the void are
actually all the same person but since
Robert Reynolds has a virus inside his
head he can't tell eventually the
powerful telepath and mutant Emma Frost
would restore his memory and would
restore the memory of him to the other
heroes but not the general public but
the century returns as a hero and helps
the Avengers the Fantastic Four and the
x-men fight so that's a quick brief of
his backstory but the reason why century
appearing in the MCU is so important is
because of all the stories that he is
involved in he fights with the Avengers
of many many times not to mention the
Fantastic Four as well he was in the
Civil War battle between Captain America
and Tony Stark he was in the Mighty
Avengers and most importantly he was in
World War Hulk when the Hulk had
captured the most powerful superheroes
on the planet everybody called on
Century for help even the President of
the United States asked the century to
help the earth however the Century
initially refused because he believed
that he would lose control and him
himself would destroy the earth but when
he found out that the Hulk had created a
gladiator arena and was forcing mr.
fantastic and Ironman to fight each
other to the death he finally decided to
step in in
intense battle with the Hulk he would
finally revert back to his human form
Robert Reynolds as well as the Hulk
reverting back to Bruce Banner so again
the important thing here is all of his
connections he has a deep connection to
the Fantastic Four he has a really deep
connection with the Hulk because even
before his memory was erased a couple of
times he and the Hulk were best friends
he fights with the Avengers a lot but he
also fights with the Dark Avengers led
by Norman Osborn so the fact that Marvel
Studios is thinking about creating a
Disney plus show for the century means
that there could be a lot of really
exciting things on the way we already
know that Mark Ruffalo said that he
would like to continue playing the Hulk
and that he has met with Kevin Feige to
talk about possible ideas we know that
the Avengers are going to eventually
return and there's going to be a new
Avengers team and it seems like the Dark
Avengers are being set up in the MCU
and now since Marvel Studios is thinking
about bringing in the century it seems
like we could get everything not too
long from now but let me know what you
think about the century entering the MCU
in his very own Disney Plus show let me
know what you think in the comments down
below don't forget to like the video and
subscribe and notifications turned on so
you can enter my giveaway for a chance
to win an Xbox one or ps4 I'm picking a
winner at five hundred and fifty
thousand subscribers as always thank you
all so much for watching
woof woof